foreign
[Music]
ER all right it's always good there's
some good stuff happening out there in
the solar system and while I carry some
expertise that that's not good enough
for stuff that where we got to go to the
source okay where NASA's up to stuff and
let's go get some NASA expertise for
some of this oh yeah there's always good
and there's there's a mission called
Dart
okay in progress
and we're gonna find out about that from
Lindley Johnson Lindley welcome to start
talk dude
hey glad to be here yeah yeah so you're
NASA's first planetary defense officer
so what does that mean
oh yeah planetary defense officer that
means I have uh oversight of all the
activities that the agency is doing
for protecting our planet from a
potential asteroid impact
um so so clearly you guys work with the
Justice League yeah that's exactly right
I have him on speed dial yes
[Laughter]
if we see you on TV that's a bad day for
the world is that because you're going
to be enough I I I I hope not uh because
uh I'm here to to explain uh things and
oh okay okay
but still but talk to folks about uh
what does a planetary defense entail and
uh how uh do we get ourselves prepared
for that I think Leo was talking about
that explanation where it ends with and
we're all gonna die
[Laughter]
well that's uh that's what we're here
for is to make sure we never get into
that uh there you go okay look at that
yeah that's the word defense that's
right
oh it's too late go buy toilet paper and
water and run so so Lindley tell me yeah
that's called survival we're survival
you're into the defense okay so a dart
uh it's uh it sounds like just a cool
word but it's actually an acronym so
what's going on with that acronym that's
right double asteroid redirection test
uh you know the first part the double
asteroid well we are testing uh this
capability against a double asteroid a
binary asteroid uh and uh we're going to
uh impact the moon of this asteroid
system the asteroids called uh didimos
and it's moon is called dimorphous
well so the Moon is just the littler one
because they're both little right I mean
well that's true
right to call it a moon rather than just
some extra debris around the debris
well I think moonlit is maybe the the
more appropriate terms
is about a half mile across uh uh
dimorphous is about 500 feet across so
you know kind of the size of a small
Football Stadium High School you know
football stadium size uh so uh but uh oh
we are going to be uh hitting that uh uh
500 foot uh Target uh at 6.8 million
miles
from the earth wow nice okay so I
remember when it launched back in
November so all this time it's been
making its way towards it to making its
way we've been uh transferring from uh
uh Earth orbit from where we launched
out to the orbit that uh uh dynamos is
in uh did the most uh spins all of its
time outside or sure of it so we've got
to move out just a little bit uh but at
this point uh in the 26th of September
that week the 26th of September did the
most is in one of those time zone it has
a close approach relatively close
approach to the Earth and that is
advantageous to us because uh we can
observe it to buy a ground-based
observatories both before and after the
impact so that we can see what our
effect has been on the uh on the moon's
orbit okay so just I want to make this
clear to everyone watching or listening
so you launched a spacecraft intended to
collide with an asteroid Droid at a
location that is near enough to Earth to
have good ground-based observations of
it so this was launched to a place where
it will meet up with the asteroid right
so so it's launched to where the
asteroid will be on September 26th
yes that's that's exactly correct okay
rocket science
asteroid skeet shooting yeah
I like the asteroid skeet shooting
better
okay so are these actually headed
towards us
uh no no neither well didimos uh as I
said it's it's orbit is entirely outside
of the restorative it poses no Hazard to
the Earth although it does come within
uh uh five six million miles uh at its
closest approach to the Earth's orbit
and when it's uh when this uh experiment
is over
will it still pose no threat to the
Earth
well you know that's uh that's headlines
oops
headline of these kinds of tests is you
know uh first uh do no Do no harm okay
no we're not gonna put it into any uh
increased risk uh to the Earth uh that's
another one of the nice things about
this test setup is we won't be imparting
enough Force to change uh the orbit of
the system about the moon or about the
sun uh we are just changing the orbit of
the moonlit about the primary asteroid
dynamos where it's right now it's in a
orbit that takes it about 12 hours to go
around
uh ditamos uh we will be uh slightly
decreasing its orbital velocity so
therefore the orbit will collapse a
little bit and uh uh it will uh only
take about
11 hours and 45 minutes uh to complete
its orbit uh so this is this is a
relative Cosmic fender bender
no need for ambulance Chasers to show up
to this one
have you been injured in an asteroid
accident
you know it's it's a test uh you know
and and uh so
we want to do enough to demonstrate that
it works but not enough to completely
rearrange the inner solar system you're
right so do we know enough about the
structural Integrity of the moonlit to
know what will happen will it bust it
into pieces will it just make a puff of
dust what what do you know or think will
happen yeah well uh there's uh what we
think will happen uh you know we don't
know exactly uh the moonlits uh
composition we've never observed it
directly we uh assume uh which is a good
assumption that it's a similar
composition than the primary is uh
itself it's probably made out of
material uh that uh came off of the
primary uh asteroid either by an impact
of it back in August in the past or a
fragment so it's a fragment of it
interesting yeah right right or material
that because it's a fairly fast Rotator
or the material from around the equator
of it can escape it gets Disturbed too
much and then you know form the moonlit
so that's that's a basic assumption it's
a a common composition of the asteroids
combinations chondrite
but we don't know how uh the strength
you know how well it's it's put together
but with this uh spacecraft this small
Dart spacecraft it's about the size of a
of a vending machine and the force of
the imparts uh under a wide range of uh
scenarios it's it's not going to do
anything but but make a nice crater
create some ejecta uh and uh that's
another part of the test is you know
just how much ejecta uh material coming
out of the crater that it forms uh will
there be uh because okay so so Lindley
you know you're missing out on some
potentially big headlines here you had
to send a nuke into it right that we've
been trained for this is our training
for watching Hollywood movies you know
and you gotta drill down because
you know because you uh may not
disintegrate all the material and it all
will be in the same orbit and then you
just got a bunch of Buckshot coming at
you okay that's better to make that
subtle uh change in its orbital velocity
which changes its orbit and its position
in space in the future and so what was
going to be a hit will be a complete
miss you know two years from now so so
Lindley let me ask a blunt sort of
physics question because that was my
college major if you know the mass of
the moonlit and you know the mass of the
of the impactor of Dart and you know the
energy and momentum then you already
know the answer to this so where is the
uncertainty that you're trying to
explore well we certainly have all
modeled it all up like that and knows
what to expect but as I mentioned that
we don't know exactly the composition of
the object so we don't know exactly what
its mass is uh that's something we don't
want to find out okay some of what we'll
find out as we as we observe it and then
uh we have a small cubesat accompanied
in us which we dropped off few days ago
the Lucia Cube provided by the Italian
space agency and it's going to follow us
in offset a little bit so it doesn't
follow us completely and uh to take
images of the impact of the ejecta and
the uh rest of the asteroids so we have
a better idea what its exact size is
like I said we've never actually
observed the moonlits a bit of us
directly so wait so that cubesat was
piggybacking until you quote dropped it
off is that correct right that's right
yeah yeah interesting so so the bit that
that actually collides does that have
any scientific instruments that are
gonna it has a measurement one yeah it
has one it's uh called the the great
camera
bag
it's the Draco camera it's both our
science instrument and our navigation uh
camera it is used to continuously image
the asteroid pairs that's going in and
then uh the images are used for the
autonomous navigation of the mission to
uh you know find uh find both the
asteroids uh you know select and focus
on the small one and then drive the
spacecraft to autonomously into the
small asteroid as a man formally of the
Air Force I think I can say this with
some confidence that this mission is not
purely orbital ballistics because once
this thing targets the asteroid it's
going to hit the asteroid because we
know how to Target targets we don't have
hit targets right okay no matter what is
that is that an accurate statement well
right but there's a you know still a lot
of orbital Dynamics involved in that uh
what you're doing is you're aiming for
the point in space swear you're you
expect the target to be at the at the
time that you reached reach it and so
you've got to take the orbital motion
into it's not going to miss the Target
by a yard it's going to hit the target
because you have targeting you have
military level targeting Hardware on
this platform isn't that correct if
everything works as designed and we
understand everything we think about it
yes we're going to hit it bit Center
that's better and when you hit it that
Center is it going to be kind of like a
bullseye like a moving Bullseye that you
hit like straight on or is this
something where you come alongside it
and Veer it off its course or you know
what what no no we are our approach
speed is like four miles per second
so uh it uh tunnel kind of happens there
at the end of them which is why the
spacecraft has to uh bribe itself
autonomously because you can't joystick
it the uh yeah it's too much lad time
yeah yeah like light speed time is about
38 seconds or so
uh one way so uh uh when it actually
um impacts it'll be a little over half a
minute later before we no even though
before you even know wow and a little
bit about your background uh I have on
my notes Here 23 years in the Air Force
active duty so dude yeah as they say
thank you for your service and by the
way you kind of sound a little bit like
mission control I just thought I'd say
that you know okay well thank you
a little bit of comes from a little bit
of experience and uh only folks from
Mission Control would take that as a
compliment right thank you
you're the voice I want to hear because
it's no matter what's going on that's
the voice right if something bad
something good whatever it that's the
voice so it's reliably steady right for
no matter what else is happening out
there thank you
so so if if we if it deflects
um if Dart deflects dimorphous in
exactly the way we expect this is
confirmation that our methods tools
tactics techniques are doing what they
should okay so now of the day after that
we discover an asteroid headed straight
towards us so now well at that point
we're out of bullets
[Laughter]
this whole business is finding them find
them early and it is absolutely possible
uh within our knowledge and and
Technology uh to find any object that
represents a significant impact of the
earth not only years but decades or even
a century uh uh in advance once we know
they're out there know what their orbits
are we can predict uh well into the
future uh as any represents a hazard to
the Earth uh and uh have uh plenty of
time to to do something about it uh but
we we need to be looking for them and so
that is the other part of my office's
mission is uh to improve our
capabilities to detect track and
characterize these objects so that we
have a full catalog of uh what is that
out there in Earth's vicinity that could
do us harm in the future and even if
there's not one that's going to hit us
in the next 10 years that's a legacy
piece of knowledge to end down to uh
future Generations that uh you know all
these millions of asteroids over here
you don't need to worry about there's a
subset that you need to keep an eye on
uh you know
so so let me ask you both this can I ask
both of you guys this speaking of what
you just said there Lindley
um this is a long set up just bear me
with the week because you'll I'll get
right to it there was a a show that I
watched where an interplanetary
terrorist dislodged
um asteroids from the from the asteroid
belt or the Kuiper belt I'm not sure and
uh actually sent them to Earth as bombs
it was a brilliant like plan and idea is
there anything
cosmologically that could happen now of
course we're not an image planetary
terrorist but cosmologically is there an
event that could happen that could cause
that where we have something that was
peacefully resting doing its thing then
all of a sudden it's activated
okay well you know an impact between two
asteroids say in the main asteroid belt
between Mars and Jupiter could dislodge
some material that over time uh would
come into the inner oldest and into the
inner solar system but it's not
something that's going to happen
overnight you know it'll be something
that uh will transpire over not even
months probably years
uh uh for it to wind its way into an
orbit uh that would eventually impact
the Earth and so as long as we're out
there looking we'll see that happen oh
cool yeah I would add to that that once
we learned that impacts made a
difference in the history of Earth's
life and geology the we got impact happy
and people just wondered is there
another
star out there far away that we too and
dim so we can't see it but it's a binary
star with the sun and that star maybe
has an elongated orbit that takes it
through the Kuiper belt disrupting
comets and and periodically causing a
reign of comets on the inner solar
system thereby creating periodic waves
of Extinction on Earth and so you can
look at the extinction record and
they're these pulse you know they're big
extinctions but they're also these sort
of smaller episodes and there are people
suggesting that might have been this
Twin Star and they had even gave it a
name it was called Nemesis all right and
so but the the numbers really didn't
work out because an orbit would be
pretty stable and the extinction periods
were not but this would be an example of
dislodging otherwise harmless comets who
are minding their own business and
making them killer uh killer objects but
uh Lindley we only had a couple more
minutes here
um I just want to emphasize that if you
discover some think early it's not
that's not only good so that we can plan
and fund and design missions but also if
you deflect it early isn't it true you
don't have to deflect it by very much
oh that's exactly right I mean just a
very small change in the orbital
velocity you know changes where it's
going to be in the future and so uh just
uh changing the orbital velocity of an
asteroid by a centimeter per second if
it's done
four or five years
before the possible impact will be more
than enough uh to make it a Miss instead
of a hit you know so things are going at
14
000 miles an hour uh in orbit we just
need to take a couple of inches per
second off of that speed right do you
take into consideration the other
planets that we have um is it like we
don't want to send something off you
know where Jupiter is like thanks Earth
you know
in our in our orbital modeling we take
into account the gravitational fields of
all the planets uh you know to be able
to predict where things are going to be
in the future and uh uh a good uh number
of the asteroids over 100 of the largest
asteroids uh uh are in our in our
orbital model and so uh we although
we're uh do you hear how you said that
they're in our orbital which means they
had it they could hit us
so uh although we're here to protect the
Earth uh we are also looking for
possible impacts to any other planet uh
in the solar system or or the moons uh
because that's you know another
interesting science experiment uh
something say uh significant were to
impact Mars uh we'd like to see that and
see what the effect are because uh uh
well that's how that's how the solar
system came to be the way it is it's the
impacts over the and we wait and we
witnessed just such a thing back in the
90s with the impact on Jupiter with the
Shoemaker leaving nine Comet that was
spectacular Hubble was up and running
just in time for that right so right
well that's how you know the this
planetary defense business really got
started prior to that you know it was
kind of in the realm of Science Fiction
and a few astronomers were worried about
it but but uh a little Shoemaker wake-up
call yeah yeah that's what that was shot
across our bow yes yeah yeah so that uh
really got things going that's uh I got
into this business uh uh shortly before
that in that I was working with some of
the astronomers that uh wanted to use
the CCD technology that we were
developing in the Air Force for space
purposes
and uh I got to you know working with
them but just to be clear a CCD is in
every single digital camera in the world
today so he's not charged coupling
device correct and the my man here
Lindley is not totally singing the
Praises that he should be yeah but we've
been developed at CCD but it's like the
whole world without it there would be no
grand kids
I remember the I remember the years uh
we not only didn't have CCD or cameras
on our phones we didn't have boats
wow Grandpa
that's great
so there would be Instagram
so they got the got me interested yeah
you know we didn't have Instagram we had
telegrams telegrams yeah latergrams
whatever right yeah that's one of the
important Point Chuck you said this evil
person was moving uh asteroids out of
their orbits into hit Earth
um uh Carl Sagan was worried about that
saying that if we have the power to
deflect an asteroid then an evil
opponent uh enemy would have the power
to to save us to deflect away from Earth
that they would have the power to
deflect something towards Earth and
possibly take out an entire country oh
wow and and my rebuttal to that you know
that would make you know interesting
movie my rebuttal to that is
we already have the power to take out
cities and countries and you could do
that within 45 minutes that's what
ballistic missiles are right nuclear
ballistics can already do that with high
Precision at any time whereas moving an
asteroid then you have to and then you
have to like it how's Earth rotating is
it going to hit in the right spot and
it's going to happen years from now so
it sounds it's too too much histrionics
for that all right a lot more
complicated and uh I'd also say that uh
uh it it don't have to be quite as
precise in moving the asteroid away from
the earth as you would be that be able
to Target it you know precisely on some
excellent point there because there are
many more places the asteroid can go
that does not hit the earth than to the
wood to hit the earth especially at
Target on the Earth Earth is pretty
small when you get out there in space at
that point Lindley we got to call it
quits there but thank you for this
update oh my gosh and that's cool 26 in
September 7 14 Eastern time now we'll
read the impact 7 14 p.m eastern time so
uh Lindley what is the website we can go
to to follow the progress of Dart
well uh the NASA uh website uh we'll uh
have it up in up in Center uh uh in
nasa.gov yeah good okay
nasa.gov and uh but also you know you
can just Google darts uh uh on on the
internet uh Dart uh APL uh Applied
Physics lab or uh Google uh planetary
defense at Nasa and that will lead you
to all of our website and all the
information on neurof asteroids uh that
we are are collecting nice very cool
well I think the real takeaway here
people
is we should love each other because the
solar system is trying to kill us thank
you Chuck for that happy
yes that pretty much wraps it up
we're still in a shooting gallery people
Chuck I'm pretty sure that the next time
they do this if they if the asteroid is
bigger they're going to call it Longbow
Mission not the dark Mission I'm not
playing darts anymore and then then
Howitzer cannon Mission and
all right we're gonna climb the ladder
there I'm sure all right you've been uh
watching possibly listening to another
installment of start talk explainers I'm
Neil deGrasse Tyson your host always
bidding you to keep looking up
[Music]